je suis moi
fasciné et inquiet de ce qui est en
train de se passer en effet autour de
la possibilité numérique chaque GPT bien
sûr mais vous avez vu maintenant sur en
radiologie ce que c'est en train de
devenir je lisais hier je découvrais
hier que voilà
certains logiciels sont plus efficaces
que 20 ans de transplanteur alors que
les transplanteurs sont des gens qui
connaissent super bien leur boulot qui
ont qui ont vu arriver l'immunologie de
pointe et bien qu'un logiciel permettait
de de mieux suivre et de mieux moduler
l'immuno suppression dans les
transplantations donc on est on est au
début d'une vraie révolution et d'une
révolution qui touche là des métiers
hyper intellectuels donc avec des vrais
grands questionnements de je vous
recommande moi j'ai été très frappé par
ces deux papiers dans le monde il y a de
samedi en 8 des deux inventeurs entre
guillemets de chaque GPT qui avait eu le
l'équivalent du prix Nobel de en
numérique qui porte un autre nom je l'ai
oublié et dont les deux il y a un
français qui a travaillé en Californie
qui est propre au Collège de France et
l'autre qui est un Canadien et les deux
après 10 ans il y en a un qui dit on
n'arrête pas la science et ça rejoint
des questions que vous me posez et puis
c'est en train de bouger et l'autre dit
au contraire il faut faire il faut faire
une pause comme on a fait une pause en
génomique et moi je comme ça sur y
compris des espèces santé je me demande
s'il ne faut pas qu'on s'empare de ça
quand on dit on ne peut pas arrêter les
choses si je vous rappelle que le
clonage a tenu l'interdiction de clonage
est obtenue l'interdiction d'un certain
nombre de d'utilisation de pratiques en
génomiques avec les modifications chez
l'embryon ont tenu donc on est capable
d'une communauté scientifique à partir
du moment où on la stimule qui est
capable de tenir